The universe is a fascinating place.
It contains billions of all sorts of stars, tiny dwarves,
and enormous super giants, Dimon, bright, ordinary, and bizarre stars.
All of them are connected by invisible gravitational filaments,
thus forming Galaxys and star cluster galaxies in that turn are quite
busy with their own amazing stuff.
They form evolve and merge.
Theirs is a complex and well regulated internal structure predefined by
fundamental laws of nature. Our galaxy has its neighbors too.
Today. We have picked out the most outstanding ones to talk about.
Cause Mo the first outer space,
the exact number of galaxies in the universe is not known for yet.
It is supposedly well over several hundred billion galaxies may
be of all sorts of different shapes as for the main varieties.
They include elliptical spiral, ventricular and irregular galaxies.
There are subcategories for these as well. The Milky way, for example,
is a barred spiral galaxy,
since any galaxy consists of a great number of stars.
These objects masses may reach incredible values.
The mass of the dwarf galaxy segue two for example is just
550,000 times.
That of the sun as for the super giant elliptical galaxy IC
11 0 1, it is 1,700 times heavier than the Milky way
together with its immediate neighbors.
Our galaxy comprises what is known as the local group.
It includes over 50 galaxies,
three of which are quite large in to the others.
These are the Milky way, the Unter galaxy and the triangular galaxy,
the diameter of the local group measures approximately 10 million light years.
And its mass is about 3 trillion times that of the sun
together with a few other galaxy clusters of modest dimensions,
the local group in its turn comprises the local sheet,
a flat cloud with a diameter measuring approximately 23 million light years.
It is about 5 million light years thick.
The local sheet forms part of the Virgo super cluster,
a vast element of the large scale structure of the universe.
The local group is conditionally divided into four parts.
The first one is the subgroup of the Milky way comprised of our galaxy and
its satellites, which may be either dwarf, galaxies, or star losts.
The Milky way is the second largest galaxy in the cluster.
According to today's estimates,
it contains 200 to 400 billion stars,
as well as from 25 to a hundred billion brown wolves.
Our galaxy has a spiral structure and appears to be a disk with a diameter
measuring about 200,000 light years.
At the same time its thickness is just around a thousand light years.
Still.
There is a bulge at the center of the disc with a diameter of around 27,000
light years, a super massive black hole with a massive,
as much as 4.3 million times,
that of the sun supposedly concealed inside the BGE,
a smaller black hole is said to be orbiting it whose mass is anything from one
to 10,000 times that the sun,
it is positive that it is dark matter.
That accounts for most of the mass of the Milky way,
which is why it is impossible to estimate it at this point,
according to the latest estimates, however, the mass,
our galaxy is approximately 1.5 trillion times that of the sun
going slightly further from the Milky way we can observe its 31 satellites.
These are mostly irregular shaped, dwarf galaxies.
They get so twisted and bent in every which way on account of the gravitational
influence of their massive neighbor.
Our closest satellite is the dwarf galaxy CMA dwarf,
which can be found in the canis major constellation.
It lies 25,000 light years away from the earth and 42,000 light
years from the center of our galaxy appearing.
Elong Desis this dwarf galaxy contains supposedly around 1 billion
stars.
Most of which are red giants
due to the gravitational influence exerted by the Milky way,
the canis major galaxy has almost broken apart.
Title forces had the following disrupting effect.
Stars torn out from the galaxy, came to form the so-called Manous ring,
an elaborate ring shaped structure that traps around the Milky way.
Unfortunately,
observation of CMA dwarf is greatly thwarted by gas and dust clouds
floating between the galaxy and our earth,
the largest lie to the Milky way.
And the fourth largest galaxy in the local group is the large MOIC cloud.
It is located as far as about 163,000 light years
containing approximately 30 billion stars.
It has a diameter of just seven times as little as data of our galaxy.
At the same time,
the clouds mask is 300 times as little as that of the Milky way.
The explanation for such a stark contrast is this the large Magana
cloud does not happen to contain a super massive black hole in the center.
Besides there are great amounts of dark matter in the Milky way's gala galactic
halo, the large mag cloud is an SBM type,
which is in between dwarfs spiral and irregular galaxies.
Even though the gravitational influence exerted over it by its massive neighbors
has as well as raised arm store traces of its former spiral struck the bar in
the center remains to be clearly distinguishable.
There are a few especially notable objects located in the large mag cloud.
For example, the star R 1 3 6,
a one lying 165,000 light years away is
the heaviest star ever deter.
This blue super giant mass is 315 times after the sun
and its surface temperature is as scorching as over 40,000 Kelvin.
The luminosity of R 1 36, a one is 8.7 million times.
That of the sun,
the large mag cloud is also home to the largest stars in the investigated
parts of the universe.
The diameter of the red giant w O H G 64 is over one
and half thousand out of the sun.
This is just 25% less than the diameter of the largest super giant ever
detected Stevenson. Two dash 18,
according to accepted concepts of stellar evolution,
w H G 64 is currently in the final stage of its life and is
expected to go super and over at any moment in the next several thousand years,
when speaking about the Milky way subgroup, of course we can't,
but mention the Virgo Stella stream occupying approximately 5%
of the entire sky.
It appears as an exceptionally scattered and dim flow of several hundred
thousand stars on the outskirts of our galaxy.
According to the overwhelming majority of scientists,
the Virgo Stella stream is remnants of a dwarfs hysterical galaxy that has at
some point armed completely bins swallowed up by the Milky way.
Moving yet further.
We will soon encounter the galaxy known as ter or the ter Nebula
together with its satellites.
It forms part of the local group referred to SD Andro subgroup.
The galaxy lies as far as around 800 kilo bar sex or two and half
million light years would transit the status of our closest neighboring galaxy,
which isn't a dwarf one.
The diameter of the Andro Nebula measures approximately 220,000
light years, which is slightly more than that,
of the Milky way with its stark count of around a trillion.
There are three to five times there's many of them in it as they are in our
galaxy. Interestingly,
the masses of the two galaxies are more or less the same at around one and half
trillion, solar masses.
The point is that the stars forming the Andro Nebula are an average older and
lighter than those of the Milky way.
And Dramat is one of our closest neighbors appearing as an elongated light
spot. It is also one of the few galaxies visible to the naked eye.
Interestingly its Ang diameter is six times started the moon.
The ter Nebula is a spiral galaxy with two clearly defined arms.
It is peculiar for its binary core. When we observe it through a telescope,
we notice two clearly seen star clusters in the center of the galaxy with
a distance between them around five light years,
a core to one of proposed theories at some point and Dramatists swallowed up
another galaxy capturing its core.
Another supposition has it that there is after all just one core with some part
of it obscured by a dust cloud.
It is estimated that the overall mass of the central part of this galaxy is over
140 million solar masses.
There are approximately 400 lobular clusters in the Andro Nebula,
which is about two to three times as many as therye in the Milky way.
This means that it probably swallowed up quite a few dwarf galaxies in the past
and the clusters it contains now are the remnants of their cause.
Andro has around 30 satellites,
the ones that stand out at dwarf spiral galaxies designations,
M 32 and down 1, 1 0,
some theories suggest that M 32 rounded the Andro Nebula several billion
years ago, leaving a Gargan hole in its structure.
This had a serious effect on M 32 as well with a substantial part of this
galaxy becoming AOUS gala galactic halo.
The Milky way is estimated to collide with aro in around 5 billion years
time today,
it is still quite impossible to model this tremendous encounter and its
consequences accurately, but it is bound to be a, a truly spectacular site.
The third large representative of the local group is the triangular galaxy.
It is twice as little as the milk away in size and has no confirmed satellites,
but some dwarf galaxies of the local group may well be gravitationally bound to
it.
The triangular galaxy is not likely to boast a super massive black hole in its
center.
The diameter of the galaxy measures approximately 50,000 light years,
the distance between triangular and the Milky way is 2.7 to 3 million
light years. The galaxy also contains the NGC.
So four Nebula,
which is the largest known area in space where stars are actively born.
The stellar nursery diameter reaches 1,300 light years
around 200 super giants with a total mass of a hundred thousand solar
masses are compactly grouped here.
These stars are young and hot with their powerful luminosity. Ironizing the gas,
the stark Lu is developed in this, gives the gas, a bright glow,
which in its turn makes nebular appear quite bright.
Apart from the objects mentioned, there are other ones in the local group,
which don't fall into any of the mentioned subgroups as a rule.
These are remote dwarf, galaxies and star clusters,
not tightly gravitationally bound to any of the three large galaxies.
The galaxy I C 10 can be singled out here lying approximately
two, 2 million light years away from the sun.
It is the only galaxy of the local group where stars are actively born.
IC 10 is shrouded in a hydrogen outer envelope whose radius is much bigger than
that, of the galaxy itself. The stellar disc of IC 10, meanwhile,
rotates in the direction opposite to that outer envelope.
With our mind boggling dimensions of hundreds of thousands of light years on
end,
even the largest galaxies remain tiny dots in the large scale structure of
the universe.
The distances between them are staggeringly enormous and even light takes
millions of years to reach the closest of them. Nevertheless,
we can still observe and study them.
Their innumerable riddles lurking in the cosmos and mankind keeps solving them
one after another, without flagging zest,
because every new discovery is just another step in our cognition of
the universe.
Oh,
I.